Серед понад мільйона українських біженців,
яких прийняла Німеччина після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії,
- багато лікарів. Німці були б раді заповнити ними прогалини
на ринку праці ФРН, адже лікарів Німеччині бракує.
Однак для цього українцям слід підтвердити свою медичну кваліфікацію у ФРН.
А це непросто.
Одна із серйозних перепон для підтвердження кваліфікації лікаря
- це знання німецької мови.
Більшість українських лікарів, які опинилися в Німеччині після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну,
почали вивчати німецьку з нуля.
Іспит на володіння мовою вони здаватимуть, зокрема, і тут, у приміщенні Берлінської ради лікарів.
Колеги з України повинні продемонструвати, що вони можуть спілкуватися німецькою з пацієнтами,
а також із колегами-медиками та іншими спеціалістами.
Це означає, що перевіряється, зокрема, володіння фаховою мовою
- тобто вміння спілкуватися німецькою у повсякденному робочому житті.
Скласти тут тест на знання фахової мови планує радіологиня з Києва Наталія Негря.
Жінка разом із 16-річною донькою опинилася в Берліні ще на початку вторгнення.
Наталія одразу почала вчити німецьку з нуля. Тепер її рівень доволі високий - С1.
Чоловік лишився в Києві, ми приїхали на Закарпаття.
І потім на початку березня його мобілізували.
Ми вирішили, що ніхто не знає, скільки це буде тривати.
Він у ЗСУ, так само це невідомо, скільки буде тривати.
Ми вирішили, що треба їхати.
Ну, і друзі кажуть, ти вивчиш німецьку, підтвердиш диплом, це не є проблемою.
І ми так: окей, медицину вивчила - значить, німецьку теж вивчу.
Наталія вивчала німецьку на курсах.
Мовних сертифікатів українським лікарям потрібно два.
Один - це так звана загальна німецька мова на рівні B2. І другий - це вже фахова мова на рівні C1.
У Берліні в 2022-му такий тест на володіння фаховою мовою у сфері медицини
склали 16 українців, у 2023 році - 17.
Коли Наталія склала іспит на B2, вона мала можливість 12 тижнів пройти свого роду практику
в інституті радіології в Берліні. За словами лікарки, це дозволило їй більше попрактикувати мову.
Наразі моя остання, скажімо так, перепона - мені треба здати фахову мову.
І вже після того, як я отримаю цей сертифікат про здачу фахової мови,
я чекатиму відповідь на отримання або дозволу на роботу, або професійної ліцензії.
Щоб підтвердити кваліфікацію, українці мають відправити офіційні переклади
необхідних документів у земельне відомство охорони здоров'я
та соціальної політики відповідної федеральної землі.
Це всі документи, які стосуються мого професійного шляху:
починаючи від диплома з оцінками,
потім інтернатура, сертифікат про закінчення інтернатури.
Все, що було: це курси підвищення кваліфікації, спеціалізації.
Власне, все моє надбання професійне у вигляді папірців - все перекладали.
Якщо час очікування на фаховий мовний іспит відносно короткий
- близько кількох тижнів, то час очікування на визнання професійної кваліфікації дуже різний
і може тривати місяцями чи навіть роками.
Після здачі іспиту й отримання мовного сертифіката С1 я не знаю, скільки я буду чекати на висновок від відомства.
Спілкуючись із колегами, які цей шлях вже проходили,
це може тривати до восьми місяців.
І тут постає велике питання: чим займатися ці вісім місяців?
За вісім місяців можна мову з С1 на А2 загубити.
Дуже важко, коли ти лікар, працювати не в медицині.
Через це очікування дійсно лякає.
За даними відомства охорони здоров'я та соціальної політики в Берліні,
від початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну на визнання медичної кваліфікації
в німецькій столиці подалися 76 лікарів,
які здобули медичну освіту в Україні.
З них - 42 мають українське громадянство.
За цей період 5 заяв було відкликано.
Підтвердження - Approbation - отримали лише двоє.
Ще у восьми випадках було надано професійну ліцензію
- дозвіл на тимчасове заняття медичною професією за певних умов.
У двох випадках лікарі отримали повідомлення про необхідність взяти
участь у додатковій перевірці знань.
І ще у восьми випадках триває завершальна перевірка.
Впоратися зі складнощами під час підтвердження дипломів українським колегам
часто допомагають лікарі, які вже тривалий час живуть і працюють у Німеччині.
Оксана Улан - українська лікарка, яка переїхала до Німеччини близько 30 років тому.
Нині вона головує в товаристві українських лікарів
- спілці, яка утворилася ще після Другої світової війни
і об'єднала в Німеччині тих українських лікарів,
які під час війни опинилися в німецьких таборах.
За словами пані Улан, під час підтвердження дипломів лікарів
перевіряється насамперед відповідність українських дипломів стандартам німецької системи.
Є два варіанти, як визнають документи.
Один - через оцінку, тобто якийсь професіонал оцінює,
чи відповідає рівень цього диплома німецькому.
А другий варіант - здача екзамену.
Іспити досить складні.
Якщо людина вже 30 років була психіатром, то для неї дуже складно складати такий іспит,
тому що вона просто фізично вже не пам'ятає, що там було колись,
вивчалось в університеті, або яка операція, як називається та чи інша операція.
А саме це запитують під час цього іспиту. Там є терапія, хірургія і загальні питання.
Попри складний процес підтвердження дипломів, каже Оксана Улан,
у Німеччині нині є попит на українських лікарів,
адже у країні з'явилися понад мільйон українських пацієнтів без знань німецької.
Як тільки почалася війна, то, звичайно, ми були просто переповнені всі,
не тільки я, а дуже багато німецьких колег дзвонили і казали, я не знаю,
не розумію, їх так багато, як ми їх ще маємо взяти.
У нас німцями вже переповнено, не знаю, куди німців брати,
а ще українців стільки приїхало.
Аби розвантажити німецьких лікарів з напливом українських біженців,
а також допомогти українським лікарям займатися своєю справою, Оксана Улан разом з колегами
організовувала так званий Аrztmobil.
Автобус, який був з німецькими санітарами,
ті, що на швидких їздять, і український лікар.
Вони приїжджали до цих місць, де жили біженці, спортзали чи школи,
і  там цей лікар міг лікувати.
Вони вважалися офіційними представники від німецької медицини,
а український лікар лікував.
Цей проєкт кілька місяців тривав і мав успіх, там були українські лікарі.
Яна Восканова - пацієнтка з України, яка змушена була шукати лікаря в Німеччині,
аби отримати життєво необхідний їй інсулін.
У перші дні ми виїхали.
6-8 березня я вже приїхала сюди до себе в квартиру і вже за кілька днів,
тому що в мене не було ні інсуліну...
Я бігла з Харкова просто без нічого,
з пакетом у руках,
і мені довелося звернутися до місцевих лікарів.
Жінці пощастило, адже в місті, де вона тепер мешкає, є лікарський кабінет, де працюють лікарі з України.
Одна з них - Анастасія Гончарова.
Жінка двічі мусила покидати домівку:
спершу у 2015 році вона виїхала з окупованого міста Ясинувата Донецької області,
а навесні 2022-го - з Броварів.
Анастасія одразу відгукнулася на пропозицію попрацювати у лікарки з України.
Вона не могла впоратися з великою хвилею,
в неї було достатньо своїх німецьких пацієнтів.
Тому вона когось шукала.
Я відгукнулася на це запрошення. Прийшла до неї і попросилася. Вона сказала спочатку:
"Добре, можеш посидіти зі мною. Покажи мені, що ти вмієш".
Потім я десь три місяці попрактикувалась і походила просто на волонтерських засадах.
Ну, і потім вона мені запропонувала роботу, щоб я могла інтегруватися більше в німецьку медицину.
В Україні Анастасія працювала три роки як сімейна лікарка.
У Німеччині жінка ще мусить підтвердити кваліфікацію. Але часу вона не гає.
Зараз я просто допомагаю українським пацієнтам.
Я їх приймаю, запрошую. Я записую їхні медичні дані - з української мови перекладаю на німецьку.
Це все вводжу. Тому що наші німецькі колеги, звісно, не розуміють української.
Наприклад, навіть ось ці виписки з паспорта вакцинації.
Або я записую скарги наших українських пацієнтів німецькою мовою
і підготовлюю усі ці медичні записи до подальшого прийому пані Світлани.
Шефиня Анастасії - Світлана Штеффенс.
Українка переїхала до Німеччини багато років тому і працює сімейною лікаркою.
Наразі у неї на облік стало ще близько 90 біженців з України.
Впоратися з такою кількістю нових пацієнтів пані Світлані допомогла Анастасія.
Вона допомогла мені. Приймала українських пацієнтів, розказувала їм, заспокоювала.
У багатьох людей були психосоматичні хвороби.
Дуже люди були перелякані і не могли спати, тому вона зі мною радилася,
що їм прописати для заспокоєння. Я скажу чесно, я дуже була здивована.
Я дуже вдячна Анастасії. Вона привезла знань, навіть свіжих знань українських,
які медики в Україні останніми роками вчили.
І я вважаю, що разом ми сила.
Я дуже маю велику надію, що вона закінчить свій шлях до лікаря.
Стане лікарем і перейме мій лікарський кабінет.
Анастасії ще треба здати загальний мовний іспит B2 і затвердити документи з України.
Після цього вона змогла б отримати посаду асистентки лікаря.
З часом я себе бачу, або я перейму цей лікарський кабінет, або можливо відкрию свій.
Заздалегідь такі плани важко робити,
я не знаю, в якому регіоні Німеччини я буду жити.
Пацієнти теж, коли я їм допомагаю разом з пані Світланою, мені приємно,
що вони теж чекають на мене як на лікаря тут.
Тобто вони кажуть: ми були б раді, якби ви тут залишилися.
У принципі, це мій план.
Утім, довгостроково планувати щось для біженців з України нині складно.
Свої корективи вносить війна.
Лікарка Наталія Негря каже, що ще два роки тому й подумати не могла,
що опиниться в Німеччині і починатиме кар'єру тут.
Моя мета - працювати радіологом тут, у Берліні.
Але, знаєте, мабуть, для людей, які через війну виїхали з України,
питання "чи плануєш ти лишитися" -
це найбільш неприємне питання.
І, звісно, маючи серйозну професію,
я хочу зі своєю професією далі тут жити і працювати.
Але я тільки фізично тут.
І коли було вдома все добре, ти і не планував нікуди виїжджати…
Це трошечки підбиває.
Але попри те, я чекаю на дозвіл і далі працювати.